it's labor day and today we get to hang
out with with filmmaker paul osborne who
sort of carved out some time in his
schedule to chat with us today he is the
filmmaker on the writer behind 10 till
noon he's one of the filmmakers behind
official rejection currently working on
his film favor which is which i believe
you just turned the corner on the final
cutter i mean like the it's picture lock
their no Paul yes it's finally picture
lock on the 20th so I'm thrilled to say
we're doing post things now you know
scores going on sound design is going on
it's makes me very happy to have that
done so congratulations really cool
regulations you know and I guess what we
want to do today Paul is what you know
for this for this for this chat we want
to just kind of because we understand
that you've been taking a look a little
bit here and there and what we're doing
with our goodbyes promise released so I
guess we just want to start with some of
the things that you've seen some
observations and then we'll sort of use
that as the framework for the whole
conversation because you have a lot of
experience on releasing tensile noon
releasing official rejection you're
getting ready to release your next film
so but let's just first start with the
observations and then we'll kind of see
where we go from there well it's funny
because you guys are are fairly anti
festival then you know you make no mr.
bones about the fact that you know you
festivals aren't for me blah you know
and I think that um you know there's
certainly I mean you've seen the Fischer
projection there are definitely flaws in
the festival system there's different
types of festivals there's even a
sundance type the festival is very
different than a Phoenix and it's very
different than indie fest and there's
you know there's different there's no
one uniform festival machine but if you
don't go to festivals for for an indie
film especially when under a hundred
thousand dollars it's kind of a
difficult how do you reach your audience
because festivals give you access when
you get into course access to their
audience through you know live events
through essentially a small theatrical
type release live event type thing so I
was curious how you guys were going to
do this and I was actually really
impressed one with doing your screening
your ran for a week I think at
a downtown Indy which was great i was
really impressed is basically you a lot
of filmmakers will do a private
screening for their family friends cast
and crew wait a few months then they
have their festival premiere you
basically fold it all into one thing you
fold it into your release so basically
you completely galvanized all people
that wanted to see your movie into the
theatrical experience into the actual
release itself and that was I thought it
was brilliant um I think I'm really
lucky with a good times for Q you never
know what critics especially from major
papers are going to say about any indie
film when you guys to great review so
that was really a win I thought and I've
seen one of the filmmaker do that where
he said forget festivals I'm gonna
release the film was a film called no
footing he did it was just a one-night
screening but he made back the majority
of his investors my thinking me to call
his investors money um within the one
that had a big two dozen see theatre
everybody came and they managed to get
into black with the investor at that
point he was really free to do whatever
he wanted with the film he did some
festival that some curated screenings
you know but he could do whatever he
wanted to PBS one of the phone I think
at one point he's free to get it out to
people you know regardless of the
fiduciary entrapped drive and I think
any smaller film really has it
especially when this gets crowdfunded I
don't know how much you have to make
back to get into black but it's probably
not a tremendous amount so that allows
you to really play with different
release models and then when you did the
IndieGoGo thing I was sort of like how
exact I mean I remember I was seeing it
we released our filter IndieGoGo and i
was like huh how do you release the film
through crowdfunding raising money to
release the film and know you've
released the film then i read actually
what you did I thought that's just
brilliant that's just really brilliant
because it allows people to basically
you to fix them out of time will be
available online for a very low amount
of money and you said it we were able to
set it lower than most players due to
dynamic player and I think dystrophy
excited to doll or three dollar for
dollar minimum you said it where it's
you know as low as you can go one dollar
which i think is great and then because
of the crowd
funding platform you know instead of
putting a little you know you like the
movie donate here don't like pagers no
one ever goes for it's it's it's in a
way that invites you to donate a little
more you know if you want to it's which
is obviously working because people were
I think what your average contributor is
seven or eight dollars yeah yeah it's
been sort of fluctuating you know
between you know high signal six dollars
eighty cents and over eight dollars so
it's kind of been fluctuating back and
forth in that way Toto too yeah to n
your and your first hundred um you know
you know discount views of you know one
dollar you haven't even hit that cap yet
right I do it i watch that I went for
the two-dollar I know that like she's
not gonna go for the cheap the cheapy
matinee whatever that is i'll go forth
at least go for the tube i don't really
good ya know you know karen was like I
think yeah I think Karen one of the two
cat that you know because originally
what I wanted to do was I wanted to say
okay we had 227 people support the
initial crowdfunding effort for goodbye
promise and so I figured okay let's do
have the first 227 people with 228
people will get the movie for a dollar
you know cuz you know you just figure
you do something like this and it's so
affordable so easy to access that you're
going to get a lot of people on board
yeah you know and certainly what we
learned it's not that easy even in a one
dollar transaction it's still it's still
challenging so you know Karen was like
no let's shoot that number way down and
if I get 200 people she's like no way
let's do like 50 or 20 or whatever and
then we sort of settled on a hundred and
it turns out the ladies right you know
we should go even lower we should keep
it maybe 25 25 is a good way to trigger
it so but get it doesn't seem to have
impacted your your your rentals at all I
mean I you know the I guess what I'm
seeing is it be cool if you know every
now and then we could sort of use it
maybe as more of a device so the fact
that it's taken us so long to run down
you know because I guess you know we're
just baby we're hoping that we get a lot
of folks that jump on early so that
hasn't happened so i guess in terms of
what our audience scale is we just want
to be able to trigger the device so then
we can start saying okay there's only a
few slots left like there's
that's left for you to see the film for
a dollar so forth and so on so it just
gives us another something to sort of
advertise or promote the you know and
have that scarcity you scare see in our
favor to kind of hopefully draw more
people to them to jump jump on board and
go along for the ride I think it's great
and you have the 30-day window also
which I think are going to see a lot
more rentals towards the end I think the
other thing I was gonna say about this
is a in addition sitting your own price
point and doing it in an unconventional
way which it's a little hard to
understand but it's also newsworthy
you've gotten news coverage because it's
such an interesting way to going and
support i guess from indy gogo and they
put you on the front page right at some
point i mean that's that's publicity is
better than advertising it's cheaper and
it goes just as far if not further also
because you're also journalists with
with this destroyed hear it you know the
whole the whole transparency thing and
deterring an innovative way and it's
part of your mission it all really ties
nicely together um and the best part is
when this is over you have an email list
of everybody's wash yourself don't you
or you can grab their emails and you
could be a hit of two ways i mean it's
it's kind of brilliant in that way um
the only thing i think where I think you
might have something differently that I
would have been I would have recommended
had I been involved earlier I think
maybe in hindsight might work better was
if you set the goal lower uh you know I
think you knew initially when you're
doing this yours no way you're going to
hit a million dollars that would be a
pretty rare thing and if you did it a
million it wouldn't be prevented by hit
a setting a lower goal I think I get why
you said it for a million I get sort of
the idea of reaching for the stars but
if you said it for 5,000 10,000 15,000
lower more more attainable goal two
things one even though this is IndieGoGo
not Kickstarter Bray don't have to all
or nothing aspect of it I mean you still
get the money just to take a larger
percentage of its slightly if you donate
your goal if you set it lower you still
might get that bum rush of help make
their goal you know jump in
that lasts like a few days kind of thing
the other thing is this would have added
to your transparency if you set the goal
at approximately your break-even point
you said help us you know this if we are
successful in getting to 10,000 or 5,000
or whatever your break-even point is
what I'm assuming is probably not
probably under 20 you know you said it
for there you go help us get to our
break-even point if we're successful
raising this goal this film is to be you
know it's in the black and that's the
goal of every indie film know anything
gets to be in the black these days we're
if we get to this threshold and there we
are and if we get you know 5,000 above
that will be able to do it give you
release if we get 5,000 above that will
do a blu-ray release my thoughts above
that we can play a city and you know you
could um I think you could have made the
goal part of the story of the release a
little more and it also would have added
to your transparency which is part of it
the thing about your movie is it
definitely the core audience for that
film is people within the industry it
just did the subject matter say was
official rejection it was the same thing
as like anybody could see it they
probably like it if they sat down for
but they're probably won't sit down for
it the first place because they're going
to go oh it's about an actor in LA and
he's giving up as you can being an actor
and every actor in LA they saw it would
get something kind of and they give your
FileMaker with but that's a small core
audience now the good news is that that
niche audience is big enough to make the
film successful um but I think that you
know because having a gold slower that
ties into your break-even point in some
business aspect of it or some it all
ties he like oh well I'm you know a
filmmaker in LA now I want to see even
more cuz I can help him get in the black
and you might have to get people like
doubling down a little bit you know
because they could get that's that's
your thing I would say that I would have
changed yeah and we waver back and forth
on that and and do you think that scares
people away that million dollars cuz
they're like oh there's no chance that's
gonna happen why should I pitch in but
if they saw 15,000 like you said they
might double down and they might really
try to push it but I think if they read
the thing they would get it because you
do explain it you go you know it's just
sort of a symbolic you know threshold
right if people don't read it there is a
intro of them saying these guys are just
naive idiots lloyd says they think
they're going to make a million dollars
or they're a little indie movie because
they threw it up for a month yeah a
million people are gonna go to Hindi go
go sign up for the side is even playing
it backwards over all and they're gonna
go on you know think they could think
that i mean you know i got it i read on
my cup okay that's cool and it is 30
days to 1 million is a really cool you
know headline banner but i think there's
a danger and that people is going yeah
you're idiots you know you're talking
about you you're not even in LA are you
up here yeah goodbye you know there's
that danger we're chasing unicorns and
rainbows somewhere I like it well it's
like the official rejection I just a
bunch of whiners I didn't get the
subjects but maybe your movie sucks
that's waiting it there you go Paul oh
yeah yeah I get that sometimes come on I
think it's a great point yeah when we
waver back and forth on that and you
know we went for the million but yeah
yeah i think you know it's you know it's
interesting you know you know one thing
we've certainly seen on sort of this
path that we've taken and then also sort
of taking time off pushing our own film
to get behind Jack Marchetti in his
campaign is I think something that's
coming to the forefront maybe more than
it has so error maybe we're just seeing
it clear now is you know when you go to
a crowdfunding there's those really you
know there's the sort of the film but
you're trying to make and sort of that
story about the film but then there's
also your own personal story and your
own story you're trying to take and as
we you know start initiated this release
um you know there was another potential
story to possibly tell with this release
and we just had a couple things that you
know that didn't quite hit you know
there's some things happening on the
IndieGoGo side of things that we're not
seeing so you know so we write
essentially where we weren't able to go
all in on this particular campaign you
can you kinda have to kind of see you
gotta SS and see what's happening and as
we're at a point where we're just going
to ride it as far as you know we're
going to write it out see how far we can
push it and then sort of let the dust
settle see what we have and then
you know and then essentially pick it up
and go from there so um but but totally
agree with what you're saying um yeah
yeah you know in terms of setting a
lower bowl and we feel that there will
be someone else that'll do it and have a
much bigger audience and be successful
maybe not a million dollars for it but
you know if we set precedents with a
great that's wonderful but yeah
absolutely I hear what you're saying and
hopefully someone else can do it and
team or even they don't I still think
it's definitely a worthwhile experiment
and see where the wild west of indy
distribution right now you know there's
no there's no pathway if you think you
know I don't do this you don't if it's
all trial and error and when you have a
smaller movie you can sort of experiment
and play with things and and take risks
um I've had friends who have much bigger
movies you know we have you know half
nine dollar billion dollar
two-million-dollar fellows and they're
kind of trapped in needing to play
things out the more traditional way they
have to have a major festival premiere
they have to get a sales agent they have
to at least see the major distributors
and if they don't then they have to find
a way to make sure it gets on to a major
platform or cable Chandler iTunes they
have to show all the work and you know
so it handcuffs them in a lot of ways
they can't just say hey here's a cool
way to try to do this because you always
don't really work any better than the
new ways of the untried it's all kind of
you know a jumble right now um having
something small if you're going to have
a small film I mean but if you are
offered a million dollars to make a
movie take the damn million dollars to
the movie is having made a film very
little money I I would always prefer
more money make it you make a better
movies you just do technically you can
make it you take more time making it you
know you have a bigger crew but the one
big advantage to a smaller film is that
you are free you can you know the film
does not have to be about making money
back especially if it's through a crowd
funding and to get back to what you were
saying earlier David the the coolest
thing about crowdfunding isn't just that
you get the money it's that it becomes
your first piece of publicity it becomes
your first piece of press and it starts
the story of your film and destroy your
story is your story
not the movie but your story is tied up
in that it's a terrific way to start you
know we got a week we had I mean we kick
started favor and you know uh yeah we
made our we made the money to make a
movie that that certainly helped but we
also got most of our crew you know that
way people that I knew who were like oh
I didn't know you were making a film
when are you shooting oh my god I would
love to be involved and I got I got are
you p.m. that way I got a pretty sure
that way I got you know my my my sound
and camera guy and that means we got
everybody perfect almost almost
everybody came through because they knew
about what we were doing by excited
about what we're doing because the
Kickstarter like oh my god this is gonna
be great it's happening and everyone
wants to go on a moving train and that's
really a way to to get it going at it
leave the station you know so this is a
good opportunity to go back into your
story a little bit fall and here a
little bit about releasing 10 till noon
and a traditional way traditional
distribution you know sort of what you
learn there and and and you know the
things that you wanted to sort of adjust
or adapt and change with that as you
finish a fish rejection release that
okay can we just talk about those two
things well you know 10 til noon we got
our we sign our distribution deal in
December of 2006 I think maybe was
earlier but it was idiot of 2006 we came
out in 2007 we done it we did a festival
run we had a sales agent and the whole
bit and that was right around the time
when things are really starting to
circle the drain with traditional
distribution you know we are the film
cost I could talk about these numbers
now because yeah the film cost of 75
thousand dollars in cash we had 125,000
and deferments and then scott storm who
directed it and i we we both the
executive producers / the studio we each
ended up putting in I think about 10
grand each that we could never adjust it
was it was never on the books it was
just we had to keep like if we were
heading over to pay for out of cash so i
think the festival circuit and the
overtures of making the film we're about
20 grand between us that so that was
about where we were
my Twitter grand was the the nut of the
movie on the cash that was 75 and our
distributor offered us best distribution
offer we got was 460 up front that was
the best offer and we were like as you
know we're thinking offers in thousands
leather blood that was the top offer and
now an offer like that for a much bigger
film is unheard of I think I FC offers
I've heard 15,000 for all rights you
know so it's basically like you're
agreeing to never make money on your
film we saw it a fairly new distributor
called radioland London films they were
to give you some background then they
were there owned by Galt capital which
is the at the time at least is the
largest private investment group in the
world they have like six billion dollars
in assets they own like one particle of
this prescription so every time somebody
got their xanax they got like one penny
and that's there was all this very they
invest in these very soft market items
so that the basically just earned you
know there was no no work involved
really like people need their you know
description to this or this this you
know component so it's always there
always making cash um somewhere along
the line they got the idea to run a
distribution company so we can buy these
cheap in museums no one wants for like
nothing and then it can spit on out on
video Nate and so they had this I think
it was Kai forget the name of the
company but was this rose new light I
think it was did all these crappy you
know movies that no one wanted and no
one could sell and they basically threw
mine on video and they found that if
they had a certain number of films per
month and they run it through an
existing pipeline they can always
guarantee a minimum return like if they
always they put out for movies a month
they can always make sure they got 10
grand back could always move a minimum
of X number of units like X number of
cable sales blah blah blah blah so again
became a soft ass off market saying when
they could just just turn him out no
thought and we make money it did that
but doesn't the guy the head guy at the
company found that when he went to
cocktail parties and he said yeah I own
piece of a prescription no one gave a
crap but when he said hey I'd produced
and released movies they went oh really
tell me more he fell in love with the
business so he scrapped that label came
up with Radio London and really set out
to try to do you know do it the right
way got our staff really integrating
people they went to film festivals they
courted a bunch of movies one was ours
and they were their high ball with 60 60
thousand dollars that was actually I we
didn't realize that was a high ball or
other offers were like 20 25 so we
eventually signed with them and in the
beginning they were okay and what was
funny was they didn't want to release
the film theatrically they were TV and
DVD primarily this was before the
internet streaming itunes were really
much of anything so they wanted to do
DVD and television and I said well if
you're gonna do that do you want a
theatrical Rex that's what we want all
domestic rights and I said well if
you're not going to put it in theaters
we want to retain domestic rights and
they said well why so maybe i'll raise
ten thousand dollars and put it in a
theater that's not going to hurt your
DVD sales so what do you care so they
got really excited about this they said
tell you what we'll give you a certain
amount of money we give you fifteen
thousand dollars nothing to put towards
with the actual release and I said great
but we still want to retain theatrical
right so we'll put your name on it your
logo on it and well I should back up he
said wait it will put it in theaters
will give you this money we want you to
do all the work and we want to watch and
I said why why do you want me to do all
the work is so because we don't know how
to do it we've never done it before and
I said well I've never done it before
either he said yeah but no one's going
to care more than you so you do it yeah
and there will watch we just want to be
in the loop we want to see to happen so
that's what I said we want to keep our
then we want to keep that the actual
rights we want to I don't wanna have to
go I'll CC you on everything I'll put
your logo on everything you know it'll
be officially your movie but I don't
want to have to go through you for every
micro decision I want to have to consult
you on the poster or user using her
where our trailer placement is because
I'm going to have to be me doing this
pretty much Scott and I on our own and I
don't it's this too much work to do
without having to add a layer of
approval and this is fine so Scott
I actually managed the theatrical it was
so much work that it put me in the
hospital at one point okay I was yeah I
have been the in the ER and they
admitted me for a couple days and I was
like and I'm still on my phone myself
like son Scott where'd it go like I
sorry I can't run the kid to the poster
run can you go it was bad you know we
realized at one point we opened up at
the sunset 5 which is now closed and we
we realized we put an ad in like like
weekly we didn't put an ad I think one
of the other local free papers and I
realized that I was like a man they have
kiosks all over that area so at three in
the morning the day we opened I went and
found all of them and open them up and I
put a post card inside so it looked like
we paid for a insert we provide put it
right next to our review which was
favorable and detect forever has
sneaking around doing it for every kiosk
in west west LA well it's Hollywood
where it was that was what we did so it
was gonna experience at first well what
happened was you know you don't really
get any money pasture advance first of
all they initially told us we were doing
really well well the theater theatrical
thing didn't make any money that never
happens due to make money in that but
it's a good promotional mechanism to get
the word out for your DVD and for your
television and you know get reviews and
people see it it's a real movie could
place theaters blah blah blah so that
was fine and we came out on DVD and I
mean like like 50,000 units on us I mean
walmart and Sam's Club at best buy and
blockbuster initially rejected it and
took 500 of them and like Target took it
we had a whole bunt loops you know we
got this um they told us oh you're doing
well we were in the black and they set
us a report that they were we were in
the black and they'd already made like a
quarter million dollars profit from the
first quarter the film was out yeah and
then all of a sudden they said well they
said no we didn't you didn't make any
money and we said but yeah we did like
you like we here's retouch the report
here here it is here's the report well
no that's that's wrong as the wrong
report we're going to
no that's not it we're gonna need using
your advanced back yeah yeah yeah it's
really it's kind of fascinating it was
all tied up with some sequel talk things
are talking sequel and we said well
we've you know that's fine they said
we'll start making it so well we are not
going to do it for free and we own the
rest equal rights and Bella bond this is
that dried up the same day it turned
around and said you from didn't make any
money and there you go and we want our
some of our advanced back to cover it
Bella blonde getting your advanced back
Italy's at the payer actors whatever it
was a disaster that was a good
experience from what I've heard with
personal distribution and they really do
the and did when you go through a
traditional distributor they take all
the control all of it and once they've
got the film there's really little
reason for them to deal with you or cow
tab to you in any way I mean really it's
that it's in their good graces if it
happens so if they need you to promote
the film they need you to go on a
circuit talk about it whenever well
everything's great a second that they
don't need you anymore it's really up to
them i think what happened with our
distributor was these just got
disenchanted with the business because
it was created on a whim i think they
and they'll think they're operational
anymore um at least it on acquiring and
releasing any new movies and well that's
what happened so it was it was you know
there was no control or very little
control once the theatrical was over and
yet people saw the movie but we're still
on their way in the red on that film um
they got in trouble Screen Actors Guild
it was bad it's just real quick if I
can't work for a moment is that part of
a normal contract that if something
doesn't happen by a certain date than
they get that advance back you know play
money for a little while or no no it's
not it's not it was really them just
being you know vindictive and weird and
it was was a very strange situation they
were also contracted to and this is set
back then sag made whenever you sign
with a distributor they made the
distributor assign an assumption
agreement for residuals they said look
we don't trust producers to pay
residuals so we're going to get at the
source so the money that produces
normally pay the distributor supposed to
retain and send direct
sag and they signed it it's part of our
contract that's the whole deal yeah
that's I don't think they do that any
other they make them do that anymore
that at the time you had to do it that
way and Radio London refused to pay the
SAG residuals even though we can see the
line item like on like visitor was just
about a sag on our little thing they
gave us and they never sent to them and
so sag came to us and said where's
where's the residuals and we said people
you made sign the responsibility for it
I haven't paid them so we forded all the
emails sag and sag went after them and
they were saying well if they wants to
pay your residuals you better give us
the money back it was became that again
it was it was it was a big mess is the
first I talked publicly by the way about
this yeah it's bad i mean i mean that's
the whole thing is doing film curves for
for the last three and a half years it's
stories like this that just write that
have made it so difficult to say hey you
know what let's go that that traditional
route it just you know i mean what are
we supposed to saying when we hear
stories like this it's just like it's so
frustrating it's so frustrated you know
and i can only imagine the aggravation
that you have to go through that's drawn
out over so long and and the mosques
sleep i'm sure sure well they and they
haven't you know the thing that really
sucks is they haven't done gone beyond
the DVD sales at all they haven't done
any television then it's not available
on itunes and we have to wait until 2016
until we get the thumb back once we get
the film back we'll take it and throw in
itunes will put on amazon and you know
at the time we'll see we'll we'll get it
out there um but right now it's if you
want to see that film you can either you
can either contact me for a live event
screening because we own the theatrical
right still we still have those or you
can you can rent the buyer run the DVD
on either Amazon or Netflix but it's not
available streaming on netflix and it's
not probably not going to be i'm and and
if you do buy it we don't get any money
so feel free to pirate it if you want I
won't tell anybody is that I mean I
can't send you a copy but
good review it but it doesn't that
people to all by the film to support you
I'm like you know what great if you want
to buy it but might you rent it first
because it doesn't really impact me
financially at all it just helps people
that scrutiny over um flash forward to
official rejection and I think with with
traditional I think you're okay provided
the distributor is they're big enough
you know paramount wants your film give
them your film even if it's a crappy
deal because you can go to my phone's
apparently I think I totally said at
least at the tustin collar and under
level this is size the distributor I
think also there's the financial deal I
mean if they may if you make enough to
get your film in the black off the
advance well then you have to consider
that I mean it may not be your main goal
to make money may your main goal may be
to get seen or a main goal may be to
increase your social networking audience
or your main goal may be to get your
next film made and that's the case you
know getting a giant advancement be what
you need but if you have investors and
you know someone says I wasn't say your
half-million-dollar film we're going to
give you 750 thousand dollars up front
you're going to be in the black it's not
a bad deal so I think if the way what
you have but for me I don't think I'll
ever do traditional distribution again
unless the advanced one covers
everything we spent plus a solid profit
and two we retain some measure of
controller guarantee about it and three
that they do really take all the
responsibility legal responsibilities
off with you sign an agreement saying
anything they screw up is on them you
know that's I think that's something
that otherwise I would I would always
try to go over the hybrid model it's a
lot more work but you know you have a
lot more control it's a lot more
satisfying and that's what we did with
with official rejection you know we were
facing really at that time you know
documentary three years later we're
really facing the best we were going to
do is like IFC with hardly any advance
they would take all rights probably only
put us on iTunes with no advertising and
then if we didn't do well they
experiment with things the way they did
a lot of films we were facing that kind
of thing so we were looking at self
distribution and we actually look into
something really cool
what happened with us was one what are
the executives that without a box
without a festival and they held a
fischer projection something about phone
buzzes left see this is gonna suck I'm
name this guy went and saw it and he
loved it he's at the farm oh he loved
the film he was a high official box
official without a box high-ranking
executive dude any medicine afterwards
that have you thought about going out
through Amazon's create space I said not
really any goes well here's the deal
amazon is owns IMDb and they also only
that a box and they're looking for a
create space success story right now so
if you do a three month exclusive amazon
window will promote you through that a
box will promote you through IMDb will
send out blast to our filmmakers and
your primary audience is filmmakers we
have four hundred thousand of them on or
email list that we email every week so
will basically give you access to
directly to your audience through our
you know branding or whatever this you
know out there their official name which
is a little bit different than mine
they've heard of that box and put them
towards your film if you do three months
of this at one point I spoke with a
sales agent who is talking about
traditional distribution and I mentioned
this particular potential deal and he
goes you know what that's actually
better than anything i'm gonna offer you
because i hate to lose money but the
that's that the high end of that is much
better for you than anything I could see
happening with the film for you through
my traditional pathway so that's what we
ended up doing we end up doing a three
month window with Amazon and we timed it
too we had a great festival run and we
timed it to what we thought was going to
be a last festival which was stars
Denver he's tied we we the big festival
and I my wife and I are both from there
and so we took the film there and had
three really huge screenings and we were
able to say at our last one by the way
it comes out tomorrow and that that
helped we got we had a lot of reviews
right around that time and it's all
truth launched off um we didn't get the
support for without a box that I would
want it just to get because I think they
were worried a little bit about being in
too salesy but we got on a lot of blasts
and they definitely didn't hurt us
Oh speechless speechless you are did any
of that make sense by using names at all
out that whatever comes down but where
you had to to give back this money or at
least they asked for it back and I'm
just I'm just so I've just my mind still
spinning on that so sorry you know you
don't have to give it back that's the
thing right you don't have to they can
tell you to get it back you only have to
give it back sure but they can also take
you to court and you know yeah is that
better sign your contract that they
after you have to meet benchmarks leave
her for the money be just go hey you
know what we want this you know give
your money back they were like you know
your oh yeah no I think it was if
they're asking for the money back we're
not going to ask for money from them oh
I see it's certainly the defensive it's
like why you pay our SEC which is a role
while you get the money back right right
clearly you owe us you know thirty
thousand dollars well clearly you you
you about look at the books I've got you
it was thirty thousand dollars and that
was the way they did you know look I
businessmen guys in suits are very
interesting and getting another human
beings in and you don't tend to get a
fair shake yeah really on your team
they're on their team they have their
own agendas but that's true with most
people in the business they have their
own agendas and you know they're not
necessarily the betterment of your film
or your career sure no I we're talking
official rejection we're talking film
festivals I know you said at the top
that were you know up you know blatantly
like against film festivals or like open
it you know it won't be the case that's
my impression of you I think you more so
than me I think I favor a little more to
the other side but I see the logic no no
I mean we love film festivals um you
know we're big supporters of Holly sorts
knows those guys are friends of ours and
we and we always love that experience
every year so it's not like we're
totally saying like Nona film festivals
but you know we're on the point where um
you know we honestly have you know ten
or twenty thousand dollars that we can
then you know take six months off and
visit go to film festival
invest for the film festival you know
we're just not in that position
currently so you know that's a big part
of it you know but really the biggest
reason is just it's just that the window
of time you know we just feel like we
just we just want to give people access
to the film instantly you know
especially for such a small film you
know we're coming from point of view
where we have just a small film and we
just want to start getting people to see
it yeah it's taken us two years longer
to complete the film than we thought it
was going to take so it's like we don't
want to spend another year you know
keeping people away from it so you know
with this film at this time it's like
you know and we all we've also set along
the way that nothing's guaranteed in
terms of any film festival we don't we
don't know if any of the larger film
festivals that we eat again to we don't
know if they would say yes we want to
play this movie um nothing is guaranteed
so it's just like we're not going to
wait three to six months to find out
just to get all the rejections and spend
that money on that one week when we when
we sort of devised a way to say okay
we're just going to bypass that go right
to the audience you know start start
playing the movie if at some point film
festivals you know see the film you know
the programmers if they see it and say
look we really loved the film we love
this you know you love the street it you
know bring you guys out that sort of
thing if that sort of stuff happens
after we start getting a scene then
that's fine but but generally the way
the game that they play is is they want
the premiere they want the exclusivity
you know they don't they don't
necessarily want you selling DV selling
merchandise that sort of thing like they
want to kind of control oh then we
understand that that's part of what they
have to do but it doesn't mean that we
want to play by those rules play that
game it doesn't mean that it's not going
to stop us from sort of devising a way
to go about it and see no because we're
you know yes we've just we've done film
courage last four years but at the heart
of it you know we have a film that we
shot for nothing like there was no there
was no production budget so we know what
we have and we're just being honest
we're assessing it and we're just saying
okay we'll start from scratch and we'll
just start getting people to see it
that's were coming from yeah and the
thing is we're not what like 20 100
dollar
for the release something around that
that price and you know we could easily
spend that on on festival submissions
and maybe going to fly to one and in the
hotel and all that so I mean we are
lucky in the sense that we do have a
platform where we can build some sort of
an audience it's not that big but we do
have some sort of a platform but I mean
in terms of like to actual money you
know we probably would have spent that
much so I just feel that this is the
better way to do it you know what
there's no one way to do this that's
that's the nice thing and like I said
you can do this without festivals now
having you're doing it without festivals
obviously you're doing quite well with
it I mean it's interesting that that
you're making a little bit of money you
know and you haven't done festivals I
don't think a lot of films that have
done festivals haven't made a dime and
I've lost money it's kind of interesting
it depends on what your goals are I
think as you said it depends on what the
movie is this may not be a festival
movie right there more than one more
than a hundred ways to skin a cat I
think one thing is you always want to
look people take a look at the short
term it should look at the short term in
terms of what we're doing our release
this way and we're gonna get valenta
people we have six months whatever or
let the vessels you know we're gonna you
know you think about festivals you think
about the first time you submit to
festivals you know the second time you
submit to festivals you've been in the
circuit once you go again it's a lot
easier a lot of festivals know you they
know your work and you can have these
wait and they're more likely to fly you
out and you spend less money we spent
half the money on official rejection
that we did on 10 till noon and we went
to twice many festivals oh yeah I mean
you you tend to build a nice the
audience is locally these festivals
remember you and you know there you have
a brand if you you go these festivals
and you're going to douchebag and you
know you can you do right by them and
this then you're a situation where they
know you they're not going to charge you
a fee to submit or they'll charge you a
reduced fee it's think it's going to go
straight to the top people it's not
going to go through the lower level you
know they don't think therefore they
don't know who you are and they want to
play their festival you have to be
embedded you have to look at the film
who this first I don't know this person
look at this film with any good they
gonna run through low level programmers
we screeners the mid-level then is going
to go to the top and then if you look at
it and it's in competition with
other films to get into that slot if
they know you though it's a lot easier
it goes straight to the top people
generally and they're not going to grade
you want to curve nearly as much they
like the zone it but who's them to
program because if you know if their
local audience knows you or remembers
your previous movie then that's the same
content as programming a celebrity that
they can say hey remember those guys a
goodbye promise well the sequel hello
dolly is now playing no TV and you're
gonna come back out again and so and
you're cheaper to bring out then you
know Meg Tilly so that's just the way
it's going to work but who's them to do
it and so and with a flick of my promise
you okay yeah it's making a certain
amount of money now but if you if you
have it available in some long-term way
up dystrophy or DD or some something
work this literally sits there you make
a film two years later people like that
they're gonna go what else it can David
and Karen done oh so let them goodbye
promise oh yeah that was good they're
gonna watch that that's going to boost
goodbye promises sales down the line
Fred I'm made of film the same time as
official projection it's called
investigating the afterlife it's a
documentary about ghosts time he tried
to take a he went he's an amateur ghost
Henry went off and he did you know is
how you do it and kind of did it in a
very non sensational way made at the
same time as official rejection released
it about the same time did a couple of
festivals he didn't really push it you
kind of wasn't in love with the process
it was it wasn't his machine to go out
there and be a huckster mentally so you
know he did a trailer for it and did a
couple festivals in siam is going to put
it up on amazon to create space he
cleared up on DVD and he hit the little
button so it's available on them on
amazon on demand and it's there except
that's almost no advertising at all and
it's been there for about three years
and about six months ago it suddenly
started taking off this all on its own
it's suddenly like his rentals and
mostly this video on demand stuff but
also DVD sales they all just jumped so
is getting you know a couple hundred
rentals purchases a month all of a
sudden sound from like for all ads
didn't really study for about six months
and it seems to coincide with about the
time that
the video on demand amazon button ended
up on PlayStation 3 whatever the reason
it's not like it it started and went
down it stayed very steady it's become a
little bit of a hit brand I'm thinking a
solid and that you know keeps the keeps
the indie film lights on you know have a
smaller amount of income coming in so
thinking in a release it's always better
to think not just your initial burst we
make the more flashy pilot cash but also
long-term you have five or six films out
there earning a steady amount yeah can
be live on it but that's that's
something you know helps keep your next
film later helps you release the next
movie or whatever it is and this is sort
of us putting the stake in the ground
you know just starting off with this
release like you said giving some
getting some of the news covers we've
gotten so far you know just trading
awareness for the film and we'll just
we're just gonna ride it all the way
down these last these last nine days
whatever just and just see how far we
can push it in and and you know in
addition to compiling a small list of
email addresses which we can later maybe
at one point to say hey you know here's
the DVD it's now available because right
now it's only available streaming so so
no one else really owns the film we
still own the rights we've created this
little window of our 30-day window and
it's just like you know then we need to
take it on to the next step so and we
can still get it on to more more
platforms we know and we'll see I you
know we don't know what film festivals
are going to approach us they have
before the release it's hard to say
what's going to happen on that front so
you know we still have plenty of options
in front of us but yeah it's the sort of
an interesting clever way to sort of you
know build an email list with with the
release yeah sure and the next because
you have a 30-day window you've kept
some exclusivity i think is value in
being withholding at least in the
beginning you can only see it at the
downtown indy in theaters you only see
it all over our indiegogo you know later
you come out with DVD have you
considered this how do you consider it
instead of doing festivals have you
considered a college tour
well we thought about that in terms of
just you know we wanted to approach them
regarding film courage is building a
platform but uh that's a great you know
that's a great i mean there are like you
yeah we've investigated somewhat but
more in terms of film courage and
talking crowdfunding cuz Marty lang of a
rising star movie he was nice enough to
have a speak at his school Quinnipiac in
Connecticut and so he had a great time
and we just felt really honored to do
that and that sparked an interest in us
so um that was something that we know
yeah Michael sir but that's a great idea
you know in terms of yeah I know that
that the boondock saints you know was
basically a phone that was nowhere until
Troy Guffey did a college to with the
movie because it's and the word of mouth
is really took off from there you know
they were colleges are happy free movie
the learners and come out it's great and
you guys have the film encouraged angle
you're like hey you know we're involved
in what felt like has involved in
learning about alternative distribution
all the new you know social media all
these new ways doing things you have
value in that coming and presenting your
movie to them to the students and say
well and do the talk and say hey here's
how we released it but here's the movie
they also see the movie so you know that
spreads word a lot like the college
students are the best because they're
they talk about it they go online and
you know I had sushi and I'm the night
house movie and anything is in lives
they bother about they like something
they're the best there like radio free
college students Bing Bing Bing Bing
dinner so let's your film for the
thousands of people doing it yeah yeah
two-week college tour up the coast of
Southern California and uh and and
that's a lot of you know I am TV ratings
and chat rooms and eyeballs and maybe
that's burn something down the road you
know II comes out as more awareness for
the film that's a great idea thank you
that's resting yeah won't know it's
always it works ya know take be able to
implement it and then you know the
follow through and all that but that you
know that we appreciate that ball you
know and so you know coming back to
official rejection you know after the
IMDb without a box I'm sort of you know
amazon release um you know how did you
then roll it out from there and then you
know looking back at it looking back at
it now how do you view
you know the release as a whole I think
we did okay um i would get emails from
filmmakers that i did I mean when you
get emails from people you don't know
about the movie that are there really
enthusiastic and thanking you for making
it they say things like you know I
didn't realize you were making my
biography how come on that in it stuff
like that you know that you've connected
with them that way it's really
gratifying and so we got the film onto
lot of people but I get emails like this
I'd see I'm going from a small town in
Texas there's about 20 of us can be
filmmakers here I bought your movie and
I loved it we're all gonna share the DVD
and watch it over and over i'm like hey
multiplying your own if my core audience
is like my core audience is always broke
and they don't had a rip stuff so glad
they saw it but you know we're still in
the we're still in the red on that movie
too um I think it was a success I mean
I'm no more for that movie that for
anything else it got me a gig writing
for movie maker and I go to film
festivals and it's funny I you know I
still I go to festivals even when I
don't have a movie some of my favorites
like Phoenix and I'm staying there and
people are talking about official
rejection they're talking to me if you
see an official rejection that really
talks about and like yeah I've seen that
yeah it's kind of cool so it's it's out
there i found out that um through a
festival director through a Bruce
Fletcher who he didn't he's an official
rejection he actually was running Sam
Cisco indie and he ended up running
Idaho International and um he uh he was
he told me he said you know I was in
Toronto and there was a bunch of us
festival directors from around the
country all kind of hanging out in this
bar and the subject of your film came up
and they'd all seen it it all see it and
they was a very heated discussion some
are very much offended some were very
much in favor of it and it was really a
thing and I said really who which ones
in who's talking about it because I
can't because it was off because it was
a lot of him I was no way used to fit at
all of which means they were illegally
copying your screener and passing it
around so I can't add to their crimes
for you that was that was interesting
they were all kind of circulating in
amongst themselves he's all you guys are
infamous oh they all know you they're
all
all that was kind of girl that was
actually one of the most gratifying
things to hear was that we made a
difference about but you know what also
about I think those are about I counted
it won't put like 20 festivals at some
point contacted me and said they change
the way they do things based on the
movie either a few things major mostly
small things mostly the you know like
one fessel said we don't we decided our
swag bags suck so we tried to find
things that were at least a little
useful to put it like pens or something
and not just all ads from our sponsors
one festival said that they had two
theaters they had a really got nice one
a little crappy one and they realized
that some homes are getting relegated
only to the crap you want to me after
seeing our film and seeing some of the
crappy venues those that were played and
they said we're going to make sure
everybody gets at least one opportunity
to play the good theater and there were
things like that so I I think we did a
little bit of good out there I think we
made festival people programmers and
directors and staff at least aware of
how what the filmmakers point of view is
how we feel that's really all the film
was meant to be for them was yeah they
know how festivals work this is what we
experience and you know these are the
emotions that we go through for better
or for worse and i think you know we
were able to make an impact there as
well i think it's interesting that you
mentioned that you're sort of
demographic for at least official
rejection was people that didn't have a
lot of money and knew how to rip things
than that we've always joked around and
we should make a film that's about like
golfing that you know pertains like 60
year old nudie fund managers or
something that we know other people that
have a demographics that that do have
more money so it's interesting that for
we wanted to make a film based on what
nature gonna sell it to you know it's
hard because we all love you know any
film we all are interested in acting and
things like that and typically those are
people that don't have a lot of
discretionary income to spend so it's
very true right i think the one dollar
price point oh the two dollar price but
whatever you want to call it on your
side is actually quite quite wise for
that reason it's like I could rip it but
if I get this one button it's a buck I
can watch it okay there you go you know
I think it's good you know this value in
being in being pirated there is thats
been written about Boyd coffins a big
pirate it's a big great day a little
bomb in this valley
you in it because you get seen and if
people like your work they'll come back
again though buy merchandise not pay for
your next film or they'll spread the
word in the Google papers yeah there's
differently some value in it but yeah
make you feel for like old white guys
then you gotta move in a Google defense
or Betamax so they can actually want the
damn thing right cigar aficionados yeah
haha is it comes it you could get the
film it comes to snifter let's took some
pool and watch this pretty thing about
my that's my old British white man with
money you know and oh wise British you
shouldn't be okay can you offer any
insight to me because you know here you
are you um you know you're paying
attention to this campaign but you know
we're sure that you're paying you no
attention to other things happening in
you know with Indies in regards to
distribution you know you're rounding
the corner I get your film done can you
offer any insights in terms of what you
may be thinking um you know your path
ahead uh you know i i've done the
festival circuit twice now and i've
developed relationships with a good
score of festivals that are then they
you know they're not the a-list you know
they're not market festivals they're not
sundance or not you know South by
Southwest but there's specials like like
Phoenix and dead center and Fort
Lauderdale International and and you
know the score of them that I've got a
good relationship with that I can go to
and for the most of them I can waive the
fee and if not they can certainly at
least take me more seriously and I can
sort of I've sort of got that path and
Blaine Weaver's the lead actor in my
film so he's got a bunch as well so
there's a bunch of puzzles we can
actually go to and sort of and sort of
um come in as a known quantity I'm
hoping to do a circuit that way these
are festivals that have good audiences
like you go to Sundance that's great but
your screening is going to be full of
people from the industry producers and
journalists and it's gonna be full of
distributors and whatnot but if you go
to you know Phoenix Film Festival you're
going to have a full theater full of
actual movie fan to actually buy DVDs
and actually
watching tonight in people who are going
to consume your movie down the road they
actually that actually accomplishes what
a real theatrical release accomplishes
so I'm hoping to do assault let's see
how they respond to the thump they may
hate the movie then I'll do we think it
but the plan is to start there now where
we were all out from there i don't know
i'm i'm a big fan of blu-ray so i
definitely want to try to do blu-ray but
we'll see where it goes i hate to say
i'm doing a little bit of the
traditional wait and see if we get into
festivals and we can do a good score of
them then you know maybe we talk some of
these aggregators like film buff and you
know there's other ones out there that
get us an itunes maybe we do a day and
date i don't know but we'll see how it
goes from there it's I think it's hard
to sort of plan too much because one you
don't know how the world's going to
react to your film at all I mean you
certainly can know that your film
doesn't have big stars and didn't have
you know isn't it wasn't developed at
the Sundance Institute doesn't have you
know John Slavs pushing in a sales agent
you certainly know you're not going to
get into Sundance and I can i get into
the major vessels or you're probably not
going to get the major festivals um but
you don't know how say you know a
rank-and-file good regional festivals
going to respond to they may go yeah you
know not for us like I think goodbye
promise may not be a festival movie
because it is got a very niche audience
for at least at least in terms of the
cell which they have to be concerned
with they have to get people in the
theater you know when if they can get
him in there by force they may like it
but they gotta get them to come in
voluntarily it may not be a festival
movie or maybe a film that you know
people respond to negatively because
it's kind of dark I don't know um so
it's hard to know what our circuits
going to be and it's hard to know how
this aggregators are going to respond we
may we may want to be in situation where
we are selling blu-rays right outside
the theater door I don't know yet it's
hard to predict until you know what what
the value of your movie is in terms of
other people so I'm hoping to get a
better gauge on that and once we do
we'll come up with some sort of strategy
yeah we got cut off this for a second
there and so we're back up and I guess
we're just going to go ahead and just
essentially rack this conversation up
you know Karen D do you have any any
final questions for Paul um well I think
what's been the biggest I opener of this
whole thing with your with your two
films what what's kind of been the thing
that you were really surprised about or
maybe there was no surprises you just
kind of wanted to go along on the
journey and see what happened I know I'm
constantly surprised I you know I I you
never know where the computers are going
to come from it's always something it's
always you know the distributor doing
what they did when they did it or you
know the fact that one of the biggest
sadly one of the biggest eye openers in
official rejection the idea that you
know I think and I think every filmmaker
with their first film goes through that
because we all hear the Sundance myth
you know it was true in 1994 for one
percent of the population at was
fruitful you know Oh point 0 0 0 1 maybe
if they went to the Sundance Institute
was that you know you're not not
necessarily judged on the value of your
work you know that that the work isn't
enough and that's that's always that was
a big eye-opener and I think it's been
it's always true but even more and more
I'm always surprised like how much more
you have to put into it is that is it
isn't just the movie itself you know
they're supporting in and there's having
it was all those little political things
knowing the right people and that's a
whole other side of you and I think
sadly a lot of times we forget that
we're supposed to be making movies and
we get caught up in that other stuff we
get caught up in you know being the
filmmakers politician and glad-handing
and you know trying to do these things
and I you know it's it's set because at
the end of the day making the best movie
really is the best way to sell it if you
can present it on the right platter that
makes sense so you know you have people
who are completely consumed with
crowdfunding and distribution in itunes
none all these things and gay incur
followers writing little blogs and
they're supposed to be making movies in
there not so that's something I think
that's right it's disappointing and I
hope that people remember oh yeah making
films in let's ask Lucas McNally where
movie is you know he shot his last film
he shot a upcountry what before he even
started the year without rent we're at
that movie where is it where is it Lucas
where is it Oh see you on Twitter a lot
you know I'm bored I'm gonna drink
something okay well you know hey we're
not helping four of a kind which I
thought was great you can also maybe you
know finish your movie where is it I
think picture was locked when you were
here shooting working on favors my
gaffer you know a little Lucas III like
to I like a rib Lucas every once in a
while ago yeah I understand that you
know I I think we all fall prey to it
you know it's sort of like this new
world you know this new indie space and
in world we're all trying to find our
way and it comes with these these adding
responsibilities added responsibilities
and if it's challenging it's this sound
it's become just just a time suck on one
hand a mind screw on another it's all
over the place and social media is still
so new that there's like very few I mean
it's just now coming into play all these
new sort of you know the etiquette
protocol we were listening to a podcast
today David Siteman garland he does rise
to the top and he said so many times
like people hit him up hey love your
show David Hill between my great and
then they'll go oh by the way can you
tweet out my project you know and
there's like all these things and and
and and you know we're all kind of
feeling out our spot in this social
media world and it's very new and and
yeah but I I hear what you're saying and
it's agreed look all those things are
important you know that's my point is
that the work isn't enough to stand on
its own but it's taught us to be good or
you should still try to make it good you
still need to light the scene properly
think about the right pacing for the for
your movie and first act and where's its
core gonna come in and out and you still
have to do all those things can work
with the actor casting incorrectly
getting the script right that's all
still as important as it ever was
because at the end of the day if that
doesn't work none of the other stuffs
could we going to matter or should it
matter but you still have to sew to
worry about social media fortunately I
really enjoy being on Twitter I've
resisted it I didn't want to get on it I
actually really love it that's the best
place to find me not a big fan of
facebook it's okay I don't mind
but clears where you find me hanging out
um but even if you don't like it you
still I think you still need to do it
you know and I think doing things like
like film courage or you know you know
creating doing and slurry things and and
playing the game and making
relationships are also important but
often times because we people with those
every day we don't necessarily shoot a
movie every day you tend to forget that
you know the important thing is the core
of at all you're supposed to be a
filmmaker and that's really you know the
tail can wag dog so easily i think
that's really funny that balance and not
forgetting that not and also not being
enamored with your twitter follower like
I love my tweeps and I have a fairly
sizable following it's 1600 and change
right now it's not huge but I mean it's
it's not unrespectable it's not bad but
how many of those are actually film
consuming civilians non filmmakers non
journalists how many more filmmakers
especially since my last film appealed
larger to filmmakers if I tweet about
you know they have favors playing you
know two weeks from now and Phoenix
order wait but how many of them are
actually going to how relevant is that
to my Twitter feed at this point sure
what it sounds like I'm sorry someone
can be porn BOTS I mean now we're caught
up with this Klout score which is just a
huge waste of time but i know the debate
me on that but but and it's just an
extra competition and i'm so tired of it
but and real quickly before we go and i
know you have something to add um what
is about facebook that you don't like
versus twitter and then we'll wrap it up
here's the thing i just think about
facebook or i don't like about face
because I used to be chronologically
organized like the newest thing was the
top of your newsfeed now it's not now
it's more randomly assigned it's like
whatever is pertinent or trending or I
don't know a highly determinate and then
with timeline it's even worse like at
least the things on my personal page or
no now they're all jumbled also and you
know the fact you have a you know
Facebook fan page for your movie and you
blast something and only reaches ten
percent of the people because they're
not because unless they haven't tweet on
your page
that we do not fully engage and then you
just promoted and the trying to pay for
it and it's just a mess I mean it's
really what's great about twitter is i
know that if i go on nine o'clock in the
morning pacific standard time the
majority of my tweets will be on and I
tweet something majority then we'll see
if this value in that you know and I can
have a conversation that time and you
know you Facebook takes it all out of
your hands i'm not sure why i'm not sure
what their what the purpose is i think
it's i think it's in order to so the
things that are promoted can follow the
top and you have less control you know
i'm not sure if this thing is that
various or they just thought it'd be fun
to make it more chatty but i find it
really frustrating that if i go into
facebook at certain time and I post
something no one sees until two o'clock
in the afternoon to see it at all you
know I find that extremely frustrating
and twitter is so much more immediate
and it's just it's i don't know i like i
like the interface a lot better google+
is horrible by the way assistant in the
I signed up for you guys and I'm like
it's just I've seen nothing but ads for
like Google buttons press sponsored
bands and crabs screw that on anti
social media that's the google plus so
for this chat function which barely
works and crashed on us yeah i think
there's a screenshot of me grimacing a
smiling so yeah that's that's really
attractive right hahaha oh ok fine line
oh yeah i think i think that big guys
going to do is sign the google exactly
right google haha pause a fine call
thank you thank you guys very
informative yeah thank you for taking
time out on labor day um you know
grilling the happy grilling have happy
fun time with the family we send our
best to you and we look forward to
connecting with you in the upcoming
months as you as you begin this roll out
of favor yeah yeah great that would be
great guys thank you so much thanks for
thinking of us and thanks for taking
time out for me on your labor day also
oh thank you were usually just behind
our computers just working on this i'm
on this little guy okay right